Welcome, curious minds, to
another deep dive.
Today, we're peeling back the
layers of something truly, well,
unsettling.
Definitely unsettling.
We're not.
Sifting through dry research
papers or academic articles this
time instead, our source
material takes us into the
detailed session logs from
really an extraordinary
chronicle of events.
Yeah, it's quite the chronicle.
Immersive journey into a land
where shadows hold sway and
sanity is well, let's just say
it's a rare commodity.
Indeed.
And what's truly fascinating
about these accounts is how they
paint such a vivid, disturbing
picture.
It's a world both fantastical
and deeply, deeply wrong, right?
Our mission today really is to
extract the most potent insights
from this narrative, to
understand the, you know, the
twisted motivations to confront
the horrors and maybe grasp the
unsettling truths uncovered by
this group of adventurers.
Adventurers.
Who dared to venture where?
Frankly, few would survive.
Think of it as a descent into a
very strange, very dark rabbit.
Hole.
Good analogy.
We're going to follow these
intrepid, or perhaps, let's be
honest, foolhardy individuals as
they stumble upon what they
hoped to be a sanctuary, only to
find its, well, anything but.
We'll explore the Erie village
that precedes it, delve into the
bizarre inhabitants of the Abbey
itself, and grapple with the
truly shocking revelation at its
very heart.
It's not just a story, is it?
It's almost a testament to how
quickly hope can just curdle
into horror in these forgotten
lands.
OK, let's unpack this journey.
Then our chronicle kicks off
with this party of adventures.
I've got Sir and Ironwood.
He's an Ossiemar paladin.
Divine lineage, you think?
Exactly.
Then Radley Folthorn, a human
eldritch knight, sort of mixing
steel and magic tracks Door 1/2
elf cleric of life trying to
bring comfort where there's none
basically.
Stuff job in Borovia.
And Dermont Cobain, 1/2 Elf
swashbuckler, you know, quick,
quick, quick blade.
They've already endured 12
grueling days in this land
called Borovia. 12 days where
and the account puts a grimly
even sunlight is only a memory.
And this backdrop is absolutely
crucial, isn't it?
The atmosphere described as just
overwhelmingly oppressive.
It makes it clear that dread
isn't just a feeling in Borovia.
It's like the theme.
It's the air they breathe.
Exactly.
It's woven into the mists, the
forest, everything.
And these people haven't just
been, you know, strolling
around.
They've been fighting tooth and
nail.
Oh, yeah.
The logs detail their previous
trials battling undead blights,
taking down this huge monstrous
tree creature called Winter
Splinter.
I don't remember that.
Witnessing Valaki burn, which is
just a horrifying image, a whole
town gone, and even directly
defying Strat himself on Yester
Hill.
A direct confrontation?
Wow.
So this isn't their first rodeo
with horror.
Their season may be battered,
but survivors?
And the cost, as the Chronicle
notes, has been huge.
Their paths are lined with loss.
That's not just flowery
language, is it?
Not at all.
It speaks to the psychological
toll we hear about.
Fallen allies Sklat and
Valenaire are mentioned by name.
Losing companions like that in
this relentless meat grinder of
a place it.
Must weigh on them constantly.
You have to imagine they've seen
broken towns, not just Valaki,
implying this wide scale
devastation.
And maybe most chillingly,
they've made bargains that way
on the soul.
Oh, it sounds ominous.
What kind of bargains?
The logs don't specify exactly,
but it suggests desperate
choices, compromises made for
survival that probably have long
term consequences.
It sets this incredibly somber
high stakes tone.
They arrive in Kresk already
pushed to their limits.
You can almost feel the
exhaustion reading.
It precisely.
It's a land that just chews you
up.
So they finally arrive in Kresk,
described as the last village at
the western edge of the valley,
sort of clinging to existence.
Dwarfed by this monastery on the
cliffs above right.
Exactly, and even their arrival
isn't peaceful.
They just had this bloody fight
with werewolves on the road.
A stark reminder that danger is
always nearby in Barovia.
No rest for the wicked or the
weary.
Pretty much, and Kresk itself is
clearly a place where survival
is everything and trust forget
about it.
Luxury item.
And Kresk definitely doesn't
roll out the welcome mat.
The accounts mention unfriendly
guards at the gate.
Which isn't surprising, really.
No, but they don't just ignore
them, they demand proof of
purpose.
You have to justify being there.
Shows how insular they are wary.
But our heroes, they have a
literal trump card, a barrel of
wine from the Wizard of Wines.
The.
Wine.
This point is really insightful.
The Chronicle explicitly says in
Borovia, wine is not just drink,
it is hope.
Hope in a barrel.
Think about that.
In a land of perpetual dread,
calling wine, hope elevates it
massively.
It's not just booze.
It shows the sheer desperation,
the scarcity of any comfort, any
reminder of a normal world.
So this wine is basically their
key to get in.
Essentially, yes.
Recognizing the Martikovs wagon,
the wine makers gets them past
the guards.
It unlocks even in the most wary
communities.
But even the delivery guys, the
Martikoffs, Adrian and Dag,
they're fed up with the party.
Yeah, their patience is
described as shredded by the
adventurers antics.
And the antics.
Apparently they've been seen
with the head of Henrik the
coffin maker dangling like a
grim Talisman.
Charming.
That paints a picture, doesn't
it?
It really does.
Plus there was constant
bargaining over wine, suggesting
they haven't exactly been
straightforward delivery
partners before.
So the Martikovs are like, OK,
one barrel here, then we're out.
Exactly.
Taking the rest home.
It shows the kind of reputation
this group is building.
Maybe not entirely positive.
This friction highlights their
chaotic nature, doesn't it?
So they finally get inside and
meet Dmitry Kreskov, the Burgo
master.
And he's got the wary eyes of a
man who knows survival here
comes from keeping one's head
down.
Makes sense.
Kresk, the log say, thrives by
not provoking Strawd.
It's a rule they obey like they
obey the cold.
Fear dictates everything.
It's also just Stark they ask
for an N and Nope, no such
establishments here.
It's a largely self-sufficient
commune.
Very isolated, austere.
Which makes Derman wanting to
grab their wine back immediately
kind of funny, but also
highlights how basic survival is
here.
No comforts.
None at all, but Dimitri, after
accepting the wine, that symbol
of hope, he does warm up a bit,
enough to offer them shelter.
At the Abbey of Saint Marcovia,
up on the Cliff.
Right, but the advice comes with
this immediate chilling warning.
He says the Abbey is holy, yes,
but feared.
Holy but feared?
That's a contradiction.
And then the detail that really
gets you when it's bell tolls,
the screams can be heard across
the village.
Screams from a holy place.
OK, that's not just a red flag,
that's a siren going off.
Absolutely.
A profound sense of dread about
what awaits them up there.
A sanctuary that broadcasts
agony.
So with that chilling warning
about the bell and the screams
echoing, they finally start to
climb up to the Abbey.
What's that journey like?
It sounds intimidating.
Oh, it's designed to ramp up the
suspense.
It's a literal climb into
isolation.
The road winds like a serpent up
an 800 foot Cliff.
Like a serpent, it's nice touch.
Isn't it?
And the difficulty is tangible.
Gravel slips beneath their
boots, that constant sense of
precariousness.
And then the mists, Borovia's
signature mists, roll in,
swallowing the world below.
Cutting them off completely,
upping the isolation.
Factor exactly deeper into the
unknown, further from anything
familiar, you know, safe.
But the Chronicle mentions a
weird moment of beauty, right?
Something totally out of place.
Yes, a fleeting moment they pass
this shimmering pool of
crystalline beauty describes as
an alien site in this Gray land.
Like a diamond in the mud.
Pretty much a brief sparkle, but
then the accounts immediately
hit you with the harsh reality.
Beauty here is always brief, of
course.
The mists close in again.
Swallow the pool.
It's like Barovia itself,
reminding them not to get too
comfortable, that any hope is
temporary.
A perfect, sad little metaphor
for the whole place.
So no lasting beauty.
Then they reach the summit.
What's the Abbey itself look
like from the outside it?
Looms.
Ancient stone walls, frost
clinging to the cracks.
Even in this dim light, the air
is noticeably colder up here.
Colder.
Adds to the unwelcoming vibe.
Definitely.
And there's this really chilling
detail.
Scarecrows posed as guards on
the parapets, a hollow bluff
against fear.
Scarecrows, not actual guards.
That's a creepy What are they
trying to scare off or pretend
to scare off?
Good question.
It suggests A facade, an
illusion of security, raises
questions about what's really
going on inside.
The overall feel is abandoned
and alive at once.
Abandoned and alive.
That's a deeply unsettling
combination.
It really is sets of the stage
perfectly for who they meet at
the gate.
Ah.
Yes, the welcoming committee.
Not exactly your standard
guards, are they?
Far from it.
This is where it gets really
interesting.
Like you said, they meet Otto
and Zeigfreck, identified as
mongrel folk guards and the
descriptions are wow grotesque.
Let's hear them.
These descriptions sound key to
understanding the place.
OK, Otto, first, he's described
as a living patchwork donkey
flesh, wolf's ear, leonine legs
and a donkey tail.
Patchwork.
Like literally stitched
together.
That's the implication.
His face resembles A beardless
dwarf, but with a protruding
wolf's snout and fangs.
It's deliberately jarring,
unnatural.
OK, that's horrifying.
And Zeigfrick.
Zeigfrick is, if anything, even
more varied.
She has scales, fur and a feline
eye glimmering from 1/2 human
face.
Scales and fur.
Yep, one side of her body
covered with lizard scales, the
other with Tufts of Gray wolf
fur, and her fingers resemble
cat's paws with opposable
thumbs.
Cat paws with thumbs.
OK, this screams unnatural
experimentation, doesn't it?
Deliberate twisting of life.
Absolutely.
These aren't accidents of
nature, they're living proof of
some kind of grotesque
manipulation happening within
the Abbey.
And how do these guards behave?
Not exactly professional I'm
guessing.
Not even close.
Initially they bark and quarrel
like beasts.
They even argue about the other
sleeping when they were on guard
duty.
Squabbling like animals while on
duty?
That's bizarre.
It highlights their feral
nature.
But then Surin the paladin steps
up, uses his paladin authority.
Pulling rank.
Sort of.
He demands an audience with the
Abbot, and apparently the name
still holds weight.
Even these creatures pause at
that.
Interesting.
So there's still some hierarchy
they respect or fear.
Seems like it.
They reluctantly agree to lead
the party inside.
It's an unnerving first
encounter with the Abbey's
inhabitants, setting a deeply
weird tone.
OK, so they get past the
bickering patchwork guards.
Once inside the Abbey courtyard,
it sounds like it lives up to
the unsettling description.
A nightmare zoo, the logs call
it.
That's the exact phrase, and it
fits behind padlocked doors in
stone enclosures.
You hear the other mongrel folk
howl, laugh, and weep.
Mostly heard, not seen.
Which almost makes it worse, you
know?
Yeah, sounds of unseen
suffering.
That's chilling.
And they're identified as the
Bellevue's.
The Chronicle adds that this
name will echo with sorrow.
The Bellevue's suggests a family
name, doesn't it?
Implying they were once
something else people.
Exactly.
It immediately hints at a tragic
back story, something beyond
just monstrousness.
What happened to them?
And then there's something they
do see right out in the open.
Something chained up.
Oh yes, a chained creature
cowers near tethering posts and
the description is pure
nightmare fuel.
Batwings, Spider mandibles, A
cloven hoof.
Batwings and spider mandibles.
Seriously.
An impossible, horrifying mix,
and when Sarn approaches it, it
thrashes and hisses, pulling
against the chain until it
collapses.
Just raw panic and suffering.
And the log explicitly states
this is no random mutation.
It's a deliberate blasphemy of
creation.
Blasphemy of creation, strong
word.
So again, deliberate,
intentional, not just Borovian
weirdness.
Exactly.
It points directly to a creator
figure with immense power and a
terrifying lack of, well, ethics
or sanity.
OK, so nightmare Zoo chained
blasphemies.
Surely things can't get weirder.
Oh, you'd think, but then an
attack out of nowhere from the
well.
The well like the water source.
Yep, a spindly creature with
three spider eyes and mismatched
limbs, a frog's hand, a crow's
Talon Skittles up incredibly
fast and lunges at Derman. 3
spider eyes yeah frog hand crow
Talon OK the creativity here is
just.
Isn't it?
It's an immediate, shocking
threat from a totally unexpected
place.
But Dirham is the swashbuckler,
right?
He's quick.
Very, he pivots, rapier,
flashing, skewering the thing.
Quick reaction.
Nice.
Does that stop it?
It injuries it.
The creature, later identified
as Mishka, flees, but then Soran
and Tracidor step in and finish
it with Holy Light.
The paladin and cleric finish it
off even though it was fleeing.
Yeah, that's a point the log
seem to highlight.
It presents this immediate moral
quandary, doesn't it?
They defended themselves,
clearly, but was killing the
fleeing creature necessary?
Are these things victims or
threats or both?
It's messy self-defense against
something monstrous but created
and trapped.
Yeah.
Messy.
And the reaction from the other
mongrel folk, the ones in the
cages, that's just icing on the
creepy cake.
Who do they do?
Instantly, they erupt in a
chorus of murder.
They recognize it as murder.
That's unexpectedly coherent.
It is.
It highlights this bizarre,
unsettling collective
consciousness.
They have some form of
awareness, maybe a twisted sense
of justice.
It just deepens the mystery.
Are they sentient?
Just echoes?
It really makes you question
everything about them.
Right, so after the chaotic
welcome, the nightmare zoo, the
well monster, and the murder
chorus, they finally meet the
man in charge, the Abbot.
What's he like?
Given everything else, I'm
picturing some kind of mad
scientist figure.
Well, that's what makes it so
jarring.
He completely defies those
expectations.
The Chronicle describes him as
young, handsome, dressed simply,
yet with an aura of command.
Young and handsome, really not
what I expected at all.
And he wears a symbol of the
morning Lord.
So outwardly, he presents as
holy, pious even, which directly
clashes with, you know,
everything they've seen and
heard so far.
The screams, the mongrel folk.
Yeah, massive contradiction
right there.
It's central to his character,
makes him incredibly enigmatic,
and frankly more unsettling than
if he just looked like a
monster.
And he's not alone, is he?
Here's someone with him.
Vasilka.
She's arguably even more
disturbing than the creatures
outside, described as a pale,
scarred woman in a red dress,
beautiful and unnatural.
Beautiful and unnatural.
OK, what makes her unnatural?
The details are key.
She does not speak.
She barely breathes.
Her body is marred by many
scars, but crucially, they're
described as surgical and
expertly cinchered.
Surgical scars, yeah.
Like.
She's been put together.
That's exactly what the logs
state.
It strongly implies she has been
assembled.
She's not a person.
She's a construct, A grotesque
work of art made from, well,
parts.
OK, wow, that's deeply
disturbing.
And the abbot's explanation for
the mongrel folk?
The Bellevue's How does he
justify them?
His story is well, it's a master
class in twisted logic.
He claims they were the Bellevue
family, lepers who came seeking
healing.
He says he cured their disease
but could not cure their
madness.
OK, sounds almost compassionate
so far, but I sense a butt.
Coming a big one, he claims they
begged for animal traits to make
them whole in their madness and
he granted their wish.
They begged for it.
That sounds convenient, and his
granting their wish led to them
howling in cages.
Exactly.
Now they breed, fight, and rot
in cages.
It's presented as a cure, but
it's clearly a horrific
transformation and imprisonment,
a total perversion of healing.
And Derman calls him out on this
right mentions the plaque
outside about curing all
illness.
He does.
Good old pragmatic Derman and
the abbot's response.
He just sighs and says even
miracles have limits.
Chilling.
Like yeah, I could have maybe
done better, but this works for
me.
Very cynical view of his own
divine power.
It really is.
He seems totally detached.
He even mentions their longevity
and how they're enthusiastic
fornicators, ensuring the line
continues like they're Lab Rats,
not people.
Just clinical and creepy and
Soren tries to lie about who he
is.
Yeah, he gives is Mark's name,
but the Abbott's gaze pierces
the lie.
He knows Cern's lying, but just
gives him this look of
disappointment and lets it pass.
Shows he's perceptive, maybe
supernaturally so.
Sees right through them.
Hints at something more than
human even before the big
reveal.
He knows, but allows the
deception.
Why?
Maybe it suits his purpose.
OK, but the biggest bombshell
The reason Vasilka, the
assembled woman, is there, Why
did he make her?
This is the core of his madness,
really, the Abbot reveals.
Vasilka is his creation,
stitched together from corpses
and refined through surgery.
Her purpose?
Brace yourself.
She is to be Strad's bride.
Strad the vampire Lord He made a
corpse bride for Strad.
Why?
His reasoning is absolutely
bonkers.
He says to redeem a soul as
black as Strad's, he must first
know love.
Love threw a stitch together
Corpse bride.
That's that's insane.
That's his grand plan for saving
Barovia, marrying Stride off to
Frankenstein monster.
Pretty much.
He genuinely believes this
forced, unnatural union can
somehow heal Stride, and by
extension, the land.
He even asks the adventurers to
find a wedding dress for her.
Not for vanity, he says.
For salvation.
Salvation via wedding dress for
a corpse?
OK, this Abbot isn't just
unsettling, he's completely,
utterly lost his mind.
It certainly seems that way.
A chilling redefinition of
divine purpose driven by what
looks like profound madness.
So the Abbot's plan is
certifiably insane.
He's making monsters thinks a
corpse bride will redeem
ultimate evil, but he presents
as Holy Soren the Paladin.
He must be feeling this
dissonance.
Oh absolutely.
He's deeply disturbed.
He uses his divine sense, that
paladin ability to detect
celestials, friends, undead, and
it confirms the truth.
The Abbot is not human.
Not human.
What is he?
He's a celestial, an Angel.
An Angel.
An Angel is doing all this.
That makes it even worse.
Exactly.
And when Surin, probably
reeling, presses him for
answers, the Abbot just lets
loose.
Cosmic roar, the logs say, and
he reveals his true form drops.
The handsome young man act
entirely.
Gate.
What does an angel's true form
look like according to these
logs?
Is it nice?
Not exactly comforting.
It's described as terrifying
divinity, blinding light,
overwhelming radiance, wings of
celestial fire.
Unfair.
All the fire OK his.
Hair like solar flares, eyes
without pupils, but all seeing
he's wielding A flaming sword
and a great Lance.
This isn't a Renaissance cherub.
This is raw cosmic power.
Sounds terrifying.
Not benevolent, more like Old
Testament wrath.
Precisely.
And his proclamation Behold, an
Angel of the morning, Lord,
servant of light and truth, See
me, and no despair.
Despair, not hope.
An Angel telling mortals to
despair.
Yeah, it's a total inversion,
and the effect on the party is a
media.
They just collapse beneath the
weight of his presence, feeling
the crushing smallness of
mortals before divine judgement.
Just overwhelmed by the sheer
power broken by it.
Completely.
And for Soren, the Asimar who
has celestial blood himself,
it's profoundly humbling.
Seeing the real deal puts him in
his place.
The logs say he's shown less
than a mode of the abbot's
celestial divinity.
The Abbot looks at him, this
proud Asimar, now humbled.
Then the light fades.
He's human looking again, and
gives them that stark warning.
Rest, but do not wander.
A command backed by the threat
of annihilation, basically.
You got it.
Benevolent tone, Iron fist.
And this whole reveal just
deepens the paradox, doesn't it?
A divine being acting in ways
that seems so undivined,
Corrupted maybe?
Corrupted by Barovia or just
mad?
And Speaking of warnings, they
meet someone else who basically
says the same thing, right,
Esmeralda?
Exactly after the Angel reveal,
they're escorted to their rooms
by cloven A2 headed mongrel folk
with a crab's claw. 2 heads in a
crab claw OK.
And the rooms themselves sound
grim.
Unlit lanterns, a rope leading
to that bell tower.
You know, the screaming bell.
And there is Esmeralda
Duvernier, the standing Monster
Hunter.
Monster Hunter, Yeah.
She should know what's what in
Borovia.
Would she like?
She sounds formidable.
Prosthetic legs suggesting past
battles, Heart full of
vengeance.
Red coat, boots, rapier, hand
axe.
She's packing to leave and is
totally unimpressed by the
party's bravado.
Doesn't suffer fools gladly
then.
Seems not.
Her first words to them are
blunt.
You're like the others, brash,
reckless.
Strad will break you.
Ouch, straight for the jugular.
She's seen it before, clearly,
and when Seran asks her to join
them against Strad, she scoffs.
Rejects them flat out.
Why?
Her reason is cutting.
No, killing straw takes patience
and guile, neither of which I
see here.
She apparently saw how they
dealt with Mishka the Well
creature.
The brutal dispatch.
So she thinks they lack
subtlety, finesse.
Exactly.
She sees them as blunt
instruments likely to get
themselves killed.
And then her parting shot may be
the most damning thing anyone
says about the Abbot.
What is it?
She just calls him insane,
Simple as that.
Coming from an experienced
Monster Hunter, someone who
deals with Barovian horrors
daily, that carries huge weight.
An expert opinion calling the
Angel insane.
OK, that really solidifies the
picture doesn't it?
OK, so they've seen the angels
terrifying true form.
They've been warned off by a
veteran Monster Hunter calling
him insane.
You'd think that maybe lie low,
but no, there's dinner.
Dinner with the Abbot.
That sounds awkward.
Awkward is an understatement.
And as if to remind them, the
bell tolls again while they're
heading to eat and the mongrel
folk howl and chorus.
No peace, just this constant
backdrop of anguish.
Always the screams.
So the dinner itself, what's
served?
Is it food?
Well, the Abbot dismisses Otto
and Zig Frag tells them not to
join.
Interesting power play.
Maybe they get served Red Dragon
Crush wine, which is apparently
fancier than the usual stuff.
A little status symbol from the
Angel.
Perhaps.
And cabbage Stew seems harmless,
right?
But the party's immediately
uncomfortable.
Why just the company or the Stew
itself?
Both, probably, but they
specifically remember the dream
pastries from earlier in their
travels, those pies made with
questionable ingredients.
Oh right, the bone grinding
hags.
Yeah, that would make you
suspicious of any food in
Borovia.
Exactly.
They're literally wondering if
Mishka hadn't been added to the
pot.
OK, I wouldn't eat either.
Did anyone?
Soren flat out refuses to eat,
and the Abbot also does not eat,
which makes sense now we know
he's an Angel, but it still adds
to the alien vibe.
So just the others nervously
poking at potentially monster
filled Stew.
Lovely, but the real horror show
at dinner involves Vasilka,
doesn't it?
Oh, absolutely.
The Abbot is described gently
teaching Vasilka how to use a
spoon, guiding her hand as
though she were a child.
Teaching the corpse Bride table
manners.
Pretty much, even though she's
spattering soup on herself in
the table.
It's a Sportesque parody of
domesticity, of teaching a
child.
He's patiently educating his
creation for her role with
Stride, totally ignoring her
lack of actual life or free
will.
It's profoundly chilling.
Just preparing the doll for the
vampire Lord Grim and Soren
tries asking about the abbot's
origins again, even after the
first terrifying reveal doesn't
give up.
He really doesn't.
He presses about the faraway
realm.
The Abbot gives him this look
like he knows Cern's mind, then
just does it again.
Cosmic roar and a blinding light
bursts forth.
Reveal #2 just to shut him up.
Maybe, or just to reinforce his
power, his otherness.
Great wings of radiance, plasma
hair, pupil, his eyes.
Same terrifying display.
It answers nothing about his
motives, just cements the
celestial nature and the sheer
madness driving them.
OK, so dinner was a bust, creepy
corpse bride lessons, another
Angel reveal, potential monster
Stew, and then they decide to
ignore the Abbots Do not wander
rule seriously.
Seriously proving Esmeralda's
point about recklessness, maybe
certain Radley and Derman decide
to explore the upper floors.
But not Tracidor.
The cleric stays behind.
Wisely, yes.
Tracidor stays behind, uneasy.
He'd specifically clarified the
Abbots warning nothing would
happen in his presence.
He figured that meant wandering
off alone was a bad idea.
Good instincts.
Very good instincts.
So what do the others find
upstairs?
Besides trouble, obviously.
Yeah, decay and despair.
Basically an on with area with
molded furniture.
They hear the mongrel folk clear
up there, then an Infirmary that
reeks of death, empty iron beds
and doors marked surgery,
nursery, morgue.
Surgery, nursery, morgue.
Yeah, cheerful.
Sounds like the Abbot's Workshop
of Horrors.
Exactly promises only
nightmares, the logs say.
And sarin being sarin steps into
the surgery and that's when
things go bad.
What happens?
What's in the surgery?
Undead spectral creatures glide
silently from the darkest
corners.
Shadows.
The strength draining ones.
Yeah, the kind that killed their
friends back at the Death House.
The very same Radley has this
grim flashback, remembering
Sklat and Valenaire flickering
like dying torches.
These things are terrifying
because they don't just hit you,
they strike with cold fingers,
draining vitality as easily as
breath.
Whoa, that's awful.
Feeling your strength to seep
away.
That must be terrifying,
especially after everything
else.
It must've been weakening fast.
Extremely fast.
The logs describe them getting
cornered, weakening, seeming
like they might actually find
their doom here, alone,
upstairs, facing the very things
that killed their friends
before.
It sounds desperate.
But Traxidor, he stayed behind.
Does he come save the day?
Heroic rescue time.
Traxidor, hearing the fight
above the mongrel folk howling,
rushes up.
He's got the Amulet of Ravenkind
blazing.
Using the holy artifact, yes.
His channel divinity sears
several shadows into
nothingness, just burns them
away with holy light, turns the
tide instantly.
Then a guiding bolt shreds the
last one radiant light, tearing
the shadow apart.
Wow, clutch rescue by the
sensible cleric.
They must have been incredibly
relieved.
And incredibly weak, they
collapse, barely alive, drag
themselves back to their room,
and just pass out with the sound
of the mongrel folks screaming
below as their lovely lullaby.
What?
A day.
What an absolutely horrifying
day.
Close call doesn't even cover
it.
So this deep dive into the Abbey
of Saint Markovia, it really
throws you, doesn't it?
Reveals this profound paradox.
An Angel meant to be a servant
of light and truth, acting with
such chilling disregard for
suffering.
Yeah, assembly a bride from
corpses, imprisoning these
quisted souls he created.
Yeah, it completely challenges
what you think an Angel should
be, especially in a place as
dark as Borovia.
Right.
How does divinity get so
corrupted?
Or was he always like this?
It raises so many questions.
Questions about good and evil,
definitely, and what salvation
even means through his totally
skewed lens.
Redeeming stride through love
with a corpse.
It's not just flawed logic, it's
horrific.
Can salvation ever come from
something so profoundly mad, so
desecrated?
Probably not.
We've seen a sanctuary that
literally bites back, where the
cure is arguably worse or at
least as twisted as the disease,
and where divinity itself seems
utterly lost in madness.
And the level of detail in the
logs, in the mongrel folks,
specific parts, Basilica's
surgical scars, it makes the
horror feel so meticulous, so
deliberate.
It's not random chaos.
It's crafted horror.
Which makes it even more
chilling.
It shows how pervasive Grovia's
evil is, that it can seemingly
corrupt even a celestial being,
or perhaps allow a pre-existing
madness to flourish unchecked.
And the adventurers, they're
left with this insane quest from
this mad Angel.
Find a wedding dress for the
corpse bride to marry the
vampire Lord.
It's just where do you even go
from there?
Exactly.
And it makes you wonder, doesn't
it, if an actual, actual Angel
of the Morning Lord can fall
into such a warped, chilling
vision, believing this grotesque
plan is the path to redemption,
What hope is there for ordinary
mortals in Barovia?
Yeah.
What does it say about the
lengths even powerful beings
will go to for their own twisted
idea of redemption?
They are the costs.
Always paid by those around
them, it seems.
And maybe the most unsettling
thought What does it say about
divine purpose itself when it
can become so utterly unholy
mad?
That's a question that lingers
long after the screams fade.